again first move joe
side come
up don't change the
pressure up rotate the cross down he do
kitty
go just the raw mechanics right
now touch
around touch
around don't get it on the side don't
get it
up contact
down on the book
in if we watch his movement in space SL
right there the weapon is doing a SP
spiral as it comes
around
back so I do not wait here for him to
hit my
weapon I actually make the first cross
slower
slower turn this
way ever so slightly turn into it then
he rotates that cross and I rotate that
cross
ever so slightly I reach for him he
rotates I rotate
Boom
everybody everybody's Joe might be a
different length there HEI might be a
different Lan the M must be dynamic so
he's doing a front crossover no problem
I have to adap so you'll see that I came
back and then in as opposed to I stay
here and he hits and I go around I'm
going to get jacked so I have to keep
the zero
pressure reach rotate boom around the
last stance here is Transitional phas it
okay do not have your foot down because
I did not complete my
cut so it's
very here my cut finishing this bulken
would come down and my foot and hip
would turn into the cut here I stopped
because he's going to get another
response so again rotate rotate
home
okay second move on the booking
go just raw
mechanics the
Joe is going to reoccupy the m okay so
don't pull your Joe
back reoccupy the M move up the circle
and then we'll do embryonic
Mach followed by the
Ste rotate the cross rotate the cross
boom up rotate across follow by
the too
much just time that's
occupy back into my rotate cross ski two
is right rib
cage right on the respiratory Meridian
get the lung again tiny little kiss good
boom up boom
boom good face okay uh don't be in these
weird things good base here push on the
weapon push on it the body's doing it
okay here we
go okay so just so we're clear on
something he has his uh line out and
then I make this X juj in Japanese
okay
pido is not going to block this you can
make
contact and then I will rotate around
that you see so but I'm
not going over here the reason why is I
want control I'm not trading blows you
try to hit me I try to hit you that is a
strategy he tries to hit me I get out of
the way and I hit him it's a fine
strategy but we're training in just this
rotating cross okay so there's contact
but I'm not to do the rotating cross to
get I
I'm not pushing up on it but I'm not
yielding to it either it's equal
pressure here and I go around it and
then I follow the path of least
resistance okay and in the form that
you're doing at the embryonic level you
want to experience the cross as you go
towards
application you still have a iy
connection but you don't have material
contact because IE is not reducible to
materiality okay but to begin we're
going to train from the material aspect
so you want to make contact and
experience the cross you learn the form
embryonically like this you're not
fighting you're just working a principle
okay so at the beginning I come up and I
make that and he blends with that
angle we go around
it boom we're going to do it
again boom I go around
it and he experiences each movement so
just a slider kiss a smaller kiss right
on my cheek
okay there you go whoa when I push down
he lets me push down on him do you
understand so just a tiny kiss that's
it there you go plenty I come around he
feels that weight you see that he
doesn't run from that weight he doesn't
try to lift that weight up either
so hop same thing as I go here he's
going to let me go around this and feel
that weight there there's no strike I'm
not killing him or anything you got it
do not lift up on it do not run away
from it
feel the action boom
boom
HP boom got it okay try it again so just
as I go and I kiss here boom he goes hop
okay let's watch the m so he's going to
go he's got to be in the range to hit my
hands good he's in that range okay ski
behind me this
time okay and he's got to be range to
actually skewer me look how close we are
okay just like uh if he did ski to my
face you don't to drop he does ski to my
face right if I demonstrate how much
penetration he had you see and again you
see our feet are much closer okay
so he has to be close if I get out of
the way then I can attack his body or I
could use shorter portions of my weapon
okay so pay
attention to that
aspect this is where I
am okay when I
clear my body clears
it I'm in the middle got it I don't want
to come back
out I want to take advantage of his
penetration so when he goes back now
going on he goes back I'm not going to
wait here put it back on he goes back
I'm following him he comes back
out
is that not where the G space is when me
Drew back
okay again for today's embryonic
training you'll make
contact when you go full speed you won't
be able to make contact but the edion is
still there
immaterially
follow
it okay try the let's do the other
end
and he would have his
ski
okay try
again all right let's look at this
strategically the form is basically a
short weapon versus a longer weapon but
both sides are using the rotating cross
principle of Y reconciling Yin and
yangong
okay he is perpetually doing the same
strategy so rotating cross reconciling
and young followed by Ed me do you get
it is he's trying to get to where his
Advantage is what's the joe side trying
to do same thing reconciling in and Y uh
through the rotating cross and trying to
fight from outside where my weapon is so
if we look at the first time that he did
his EDI right how did I deal with that
is not by going straight back
out but rotating the entire fight the
entire fight is the cross and I'm going
to rotate it okay so we pay attention to
that part now as I move over here so my
entry if you pay attention was one two
rotate I'm going to do it
again he does Ed me I rotate it he's
going to do Ed me again you see and I'm
going to rotate again to get back out of
this
fight back
out
rotate rotate the
fight rotate the
fight we'll Mal make contact and
embryonically do the FL I fall
down
around
[Music]
ski rotate rotate the
fight rotate rotate the like
down okay let's try
it so he kisses rotates the cross I move
up the circle I rotate the fight boom I
rotate the cross he keeps connection
here I go back out to my range okay but
pay attention to what's happening before
you touch the ban again
okay
up Bo look slow here he's going around
look what I'm
doing I in the same way and he follows
my Joe in I will follow his book in
around okay
okay got it don't sit there and wait for
it it's like he's not waiting for my
movement now he's making
contact Bo he's keeping contact I don't
want to wa here and
block
okay now it's embryonic training no
longer a sword cut just a
vector I am going to go straight down
and then rotate the cross it's a yinyang
world sometimes I rotate the cross and
then go down this time I'm going down
and then rotate the cross got it so
don't
rotate the
cross go
down got it and then rotate the
cross embryonic training that's how
we're going to do it embryonic that's
how we train that technique
embryonically embryonic training my
hands back here embryonic don't have it
out out here out here then down boom
Another then
[Music]
complete okay try to
again so I go on and that Joe is between
he and I do you see
that when I spin the fight that I'm too
close now now I'm into all the other
parts of the sword in the empty
hand I move to my
range same thing's going to happen here
I move to my range you
see my range not here same thing the
Suka everything is his empty hands you
can't be you don't don't just do the
form go back to your range your range
your range boom hop your range you see
how it fits in there you got it I'm just
scraping it scraping it scraping it now
we're here boom and then in okay try it
again
just home rotate fight down keep the
adhesion for he comes around I'm going
to keep the adhesion
going I'm employing the same strategy e
me try to get to my advantage a shorter
weapon just like I'm a shorter guy I
don't want to fight Taylor out here I
got to get inside his legs and Stripes
you understand that
okay
Bo stick stick
stick home
stick
he rotates the cross of the fight he
rotates the joke I rotate the
bul comes in I'm going to rotate this
and use my strategy again fully de
me
here as he goes back I
stick he goes back I stick same thing
here boom I
stick okay let's try it
go okay so uh you could tell uh the
rotating cross is constant one's working
through one's working through Tenon if
you pay attention and then the whole
fight geometry has to change too one has
Yang weapon one has a Yin weapon so this
pattern is is the whole Cosmos okay
working together that's what you're
doing here um so make sure you do your
rolles don't you don't do uh Yin ten Con
on the side that is
y got it okay and just like you does
that mean I'm I don't have any of the
other
aspect yes you do we have a pattern
there's clearly a circle on each side of
the other element but it is predominant
one okay so as we come along and we're
going boom to see how I go
forward I'm not here going hovering on
the
outside and so my my mind my spirit
changes you see so here this is like
falsey do you
understand so the kiss is not is not uh
I do not mean
it just like a light touch it's like a
eduction do you see now your
mind you understand it's like for play
okay so I don't want I'm not out here
and going Kiss
Kiss Kiss Boom in okay he goes boom he
yields same thing here that yield is
fake
seduction back in okay he goes around
again he he's going to yield again I
again doing a fake yield so now I have
to do full full y you got it and I'm not
going to hover around the outside on a
circle I'm going to go straight in
straight straight into
that in that regard it is very important
that I have the rotating cross because
it maintains my angle of
deflection through the phase I am on the
line of attack okay so he
goes he
goes okay watch go there's his line if I
stay there if I start going off the
cross is
off
here I am I'm going to go under it
keeping
it till my hips
rotate don't swing that cross at the end
go don't swing at the beginning I mean
don't swing in at the
beginning wait till the end
okay try it yeah